(electonic music)
- This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website, or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
with the Institute of
International Studies.
Our guest today is V.S. Ramachandran
who is Director of the Center
for Brain and Cognition
and Distinguished Professor
with the Psychology Department
and Neurosciences Program
at the University of California San Diego.
He's also Adjunct Professor of Biology
at the Salk Institute.
He is the 2016 Foerster Lecturer
on the immortality of
the soul at UC Berkeley.
Welcome to our program, Doctor.
- Thank you, Harry, I'm
delighted to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Chennai in India,
and early schooling was in Chennai.
But then I also spent part of
my time in Bangkok, Thailand
where my father was a diplomat.
- And looking back, how did your parents
shape your thinking about the world?
- My father was a bit aloof, by and large,
a man of the world, and
always wanted to push me
into medicine and do well in life.
Mother was more idealistic and religious,
steeped in Indian mythology and tradition.
So I had these two different
influences on my life.
My mother was more academically inclined.
- And who pushed you into sciences,
or was that just something
you embraced on your own?
- I embraced on my own, but partly,
I had very good teachers in school.
I went to a British school.
- In India now?
- In Thailand.
- In Thailand, yeah.
- My father worked for
the United Nations there.
And I had a teacher named Mrs. Vaneet,
Mrs. Panatura there,
who demonstrate chemistry
experiments in the lab,
give us chemicals to take to our homes,
experiment with, something
that would never happen
in this day and age because
of liability issues.
I remember Mrs. Panatura showing us
if you take a piece
of, if you take a nail,
an iron nail, put it in copper
sulfate, a blue solution,
the iron became copper.
This is like magic.
You have a blue solution, you
can't see anything red in it,
you put an iron nail in
it and it becomes red,
it becomes copper, how is this possible?
And that's how we got
started on chemistry.
- And what was it about
science at that early age
that attracted you?
Besides the good teachers, obviously.
- I think the idea that it's,
in a funny way, the
idea that it's divorced
from the real world,
that you have this microcosm
where you're on your own,
and you do your experiments
with a few kindred spirits.
I felt isolated from other kids.
I was not very much into sports.
There was one other kid
named Samtao Sujeritco,
Cookie, this classmate of mine.
He and I would sneak off and
do experiments in the basement.
- And there must, from what
you said about your mother,
there must be an influence there
in sort of seeing things
that are latent basically
because you see the experiment,
you see what happens,
but to understand it, you have
to come to understand laws
that aren't visible in a way.
- Now I won't say it's that specific,
more the general academic
slant in my mind,
exploring natural phenomena,
making discoveries,
that came from my mother,
the urge to do that,
but the specific strategy
of doing experiments,
and the excitement of doing experiments
came from my school
teachers primarily I think.
I like to think it's party
also innate, but who knows.
- And you wound up doing
experiments on your own
as a young person?
- Yeah but always in
consultation with my teachers,
and I'd do it at home, go
tell my teachers about it,
they'd get excited about it,
they'd tell other students,
very, very iterative process, those days.
- And what was it like
growing up in Thailand?
Did you experience that
setting and that culture,
or were you isolated?
- I was more or less isolated.
I went to this school called
the Bangkok British School,
or Patana School, and the
teachers were excellent,
that made a huge, big difference.
Very inspiring and inspired teachers.
- And so when you went on to college,
where did you go to college,
and was it inevitable that
you would do the sciences?
- Well, yeah, I decided very early on
I'm gonna go do science.
And I decided on a career in medicine.
My father was insistent
that I take medicine
rather than science.
- He was worried about
you making a living.
- Right, especially in India in that time.
It'd be very difficult to make a career
out of pure science, so,
and my mother encouraged me to do science.
I was conflicted.
And then one of my
uncles, one of my aunts,
one of my cousins is a
distinguished physician.
And she told me you can
get the best of both worlds
by doing medicine because
you can have one foot
in academic science, academic medicine,
and one foot in medical practice.
If you ever fail as a scientist,
you can always be a good doctor.
- And so what, in the early years,
what sub-fields in science attracted you?
- I would say mostly chemistry
very early on was exciting.
Just the big bang and
the colorful displays,
to put it crudely,
but also just the notion
that from a few elementary interactions,
a whole spectrum of
phenomena in the universe
is derived from the
elementary interactions.
The periodic table and
things of that nature.
So that excited me in chemistry.
Biology was interesting
because of its complexity.
So I was always interested
in evolution and fossils
and dinosaurs as most kids are,
had an interest in archeology.
If you think about these things,
archeology, chemistry,
paleontology, evolution,
most kids are interested in this,
and they lose interest very quickly.
I don't know why, I just
happened to retain this interest,
and if I weren't doing neurology,
I would be doing probably archeology,
or evolutionary biology,
developmental biology.
- And we'll talk about this later,
but evolution is something
still in the back of your mind
as you look for the origins
of phenomena in the brain.
- Absolutely.
- Now what about medicine?
One thing that must have
really made a difference
in your life in medicine
was the clinical experience.
- Absolutely, yeah, fascinating.
- Yeah.
- And a bit like Conan Doyle
being inspired by his teacher
to write Sherlock Holmes novels.
Pardon the lofty comparison,
but what I meant to say is that
when you're doing medicine,
often you have little clues
you have to latch onto.
In those days, we don't
have CT, we don't have MR,
we don't have fancy diagnostic
tools, so very often,
very quickly you had to arrive
at what we call a spot diagnosis
based on few simple clues
you see in the patient.
- And also talking to
the patient is important.
- Exactly, one of the first things
every medical student is taught
is that 90% of the time
we arrive at the diagnosis
from the history.
You don't need to do any testing.
Then the physical exam
will clinch the diagnosis.
You don't need to do any
lab tests most of the time.
This is no longer practice of course.
We don't need to in a sense.
But that gives you,
emphasizes the detective,
like the Sherlock Holmes
aspect of medicine.
- And you also obtained a PhD?
- Yeah, from India, I went
to Cambridge, England,
obtained a PhD in visual neuroscience,
visual perception.
- And so you lay the groundwork
for what would later become
your study of the brain,
and vision was, the study
of perception and vision,
was an important stepping stone
to the way you would
think about the brain.
- That's a very accurate description.
When I was in India,
fascinated by neurology,
but not much research I
could do at that time.
And I finally could do
experiments in vision
using very simple equipment
which was available at that time,
and what I specialize in is
studying visual illusions.
We look at the world, it's all out there,
and we think, we take it for granted.
You open your eyes in
the morning and viola,
so a lot of that, you take it for granted.
But in fact if you think about it,
there's two little distorted
image in your eyeball,
what you see is a three
dimensional world out there.
How does this transformation come about?
It's taking place in all the
visual areas in your brain.
So brain is using a code,
creating a symbolic description
of objects and events in the world,
and we're like cryptographers
trying to crack these alien code,
that's what the study of vision is.
So an illusion is an anomaly,
gives you a golden key,
to understanding normal visual function.
- You actually quote in your book,
beginning of one of the chapters,
you quote Sherlock Holmes,
and you say, where Holmes says,
"I know, my dear Watson,
that you share my love
"of all that is bizarre
and outside the conventions
"and humdrum routine of everyday life."
So that's another element,
- Yeah.
- That came into your thinking.
Hallucinations and then
the bizarre in a way.
- Yeah, I mean I don't know
if it's healthy or not,
and I don't know how much
it's helped my research,
but I like to think it has.
I go after anomalies, things
which seem like oddities,
which people have ignored for a long time.
And neurology is full of
oddities and anomalies.
There are syndromes
which nobody has studied
that have been around for a hundred years,
and I've made a career out of this,
going to the clinic, bringing the patient
from the clinic to the laboratory,
studying them intensively,
finding out what's wrong with them,
and then sometimes devising a therapy.
We did this with synesthesia,
with not a patient but an
otherwise normal person,
every time he sees a number,
he sees a particular color.
We did it with phantom limbs.
Of course the strategy
doesn't always work.
You only hear the success stories.
Nine out of 10 times, we fail,
and it's just some cooky disorder,
sometimes outright bogus,
and I'll give you an example of this.
The disorder called de
Clérambault syndrome,
have you heard of this?
- No, no.
- This refers to, it's
officially recognized
by the psychology establishment,
it refers to a young woman
who develops a delusion
that this old, rich, famous
man is madly in love with her
but is in denial about it.
An actual named syndrome.
Of course it's nonsense,
there's no such syndrome.
Ironically there's no name
for the equivalent syndrome
where an older, famous, rich
gentleman holds the delusion
that this young hottie is in love with him
but in denial about it.
This is much more common
and because syndromes
are described by male psychiatrists.
- So this is the stuff of screenplays.
- That's correct.
- But not neurology.
- Not neurology, yeah.
There's another one called
chronic underachievement syndrome
which we used to call stupidity.
(laughing)
- In your book I think in the epilogue,
you have a quote which I
wanna read now, you say,
"Neurology, we now are at the same stage
"that chemistry was in the 19th Century,
"discovering the basic elements,
"grouping them into categories,
"and studying their interactions."
I raise that because one of the things
that come up in your
background in your early years
you were fascinated by
19th Century science.
- Yeah.
- And the simplicity of
the early experiments
when the fields were being established.
Talk a little about that.
- Yeah I mean all the famous
experiments in science
should be included in our
undergraduate curriculum I think
as a separate course.
We're starting to do this at UCSD,
and it should be done
at all the UC campuses,
indeed all the universities.
For example, take Faraday,
you know, you took a wire,
simply out of a hunch,
took a coil and moved a rod, an iron rod,
to and fro in the coil, and
generated an electric current,
thereby bridging two completely unrelated,
seemingly unrelated fields of physics,
electricity and magnetism.
It took him five minutes
to do the experiment.
Another one of my favorite examples,
Newton's prison experiment.
I'm stating the obvious here,
everybody learns this in
school, but just to recap.
Everybody thinks Newton passed white light
through a prism and discovered
it's made of seven colors.
In fact that's not true.
Known long before Newton,
people were using
chandeliers for that reason.
They knew white light would
be converted to colors.
But people thought it was because
of impurities in the glass
and the prism was converting white light
into colored spectrum.
Newton said it's not
impurities in the glass,
it's just white light is
made up of seven wavelengths.
And so what they did was,
the critics kept claiming that
it's impurities in the glass,
the people who supported Newton
spent years and years, decades,
polishing the glass,
removing the impurities,
and showing the colors were still there.
This went on and on for years and years,
no matter how pure the glass was,
the critics would claim there's
some impurities in there.
Newton looked at this debate,
and it took him five minutes
to disprove the opposition.
All he did was he took the prism,
passed white light through it,
it split into seven colors.
Then you put another prism upside down.
Now the impurities should
become even more colorful.
In fact it turns back into white light.
This is what he calls
the crucial experiment.
In science, it doesn't work
if you just keep doing more
and more experiments to prove your point.
What's important is you
do the crucial experiment
for the experiment at hand.
So I was fascinated by the
simplicity of Newton's approach.
And indeed hundreds of
Victorian scientists,
not just Newton.
- It's interesting because that embrace
of a 19th Century science combined with,
you were working in India
and then in Thailand,
a place where low tech
was not only a virtue,
but it was a necessity.
- Yes.
- Talk a little about that
because what I'm really
getting of sense of
is how these forces all
from your background
come together to shape where you wanna go.
- Yes, I mean especially
in clinical medicine,
the absence of technology, high
tech diagnostic techniques,
we had to rely on
intuition, rely on logic,
rely on simple observation of the patient
using a sort of Bayesian approach,
and then come up with
a plausible diagnosis,
and 90% of the time you have
your diagnosis right there,
so the emphasis is on
simplicity and elegance
of approaching a problem, rather than,
it's concept driven,
not methodology driven,
I've always believed that about science.
You don't want to be a Luddite obviously,
science is driven by technology,
where would we be without
the microscope or telescope,
it opened up whole worlds,
but the instrument should
not be the end in itself.
- And so in a funny way,
all the technology now
is for you a dessert, basically,
because you really are starting out
at a very simple, conceptual level,
interacting with the patient,
and then maybe using
the machinery to confirm
or disconfirm.
- That's absolutely right,
that's exactly the way
it should be done, not
a fishing expedition.
Very often you adopt the
role of a five year old child
given a knife.
A five year old child given a knife
just goes and cuts everything.
That should not happen obviously.
- I like to ask my guests
what they see as the
skills and temperament
that students should
manifest or acquire or learn
so that they can do the work in your case
of studying the brain.
- Well I think studying
any area of science,
to become a creative scientist
who enjoys what you do,
it's important to hang around people
who are passionate about what they do,
it seems like an obvious thing,
but there's nothing more
contagious than passion,
so that's the first thing.
And then read widely outside your field,
not just in your own narrow cul-de-sac
because often cross-fertilization of ideas
is what leads to major
discoveries in science.
And I also notice, this
may be an odd thing to say,
humor helps, and some
of my best experiments
came out of jokes, saying
this guy has a phantom limb,
what would happen if we put
a mirror in front of him,
or what would happen if
you touched his face?
I can give you lots of examples.
- So there's a joking, but
also there's a playfulness.
- That's correct, that's correct.
- Yeah.
- The playfulness is important
because in humor, humor involves
an unusual juxtaposition
of ideas, seeing things
from a novel vantage point.
That's also the basis of
scientific creativity,
so it may not be a coincidence
that one can often lead
to the other.
- And in a way in humor,
implicit in humor,
is a sense of the structure,
that is, how things
hold together in a way,
and then making a humorous comment,
and people may not see the structure,
but they get the humor.
- That's correct.
- Yeah, and what about patience
as part of the temperament
because it must be the case in your work
that a lot of what you think
may be a useful concept
turns out to be a dead end.
- Patience or patients? P-a-t-i,
- Patience meaning,
- Impatient versus patience.
- Yeah, not being impatient.
- Right.
- Being able, and this must
go with the playfulness,
to sort of hold things, look at them,
go in a particular direction,
but then find out it's not the right.
- Know when to give up, too.
- Yeah.
- As I mentioned, there
are these bogus syndromes.
- Yeah.
- And you can waste a whole lifetime
studying the bogus syndromes,
so you have to have tenacity,
but you also have to have good judgment,
enough to realize this is a dead end,
and patience is of course
a virtue in this case.
- Now at one point in your book,
you say something which
I found intriguing,
you said,
"If an elaborate theory cannot predict
"what your grandmother
knows using common sense,
"then it isn't worth much."
So the simplicity and elegance in method
also leads to a simplicity in stating
what you think is going on.
- Yeah, I think the
grandmother example is twofold.
First of all, you should be able
to express your ideas clearly enough
that your grandmother understands them.
If I do an experiment on phantom limbs,
I should be able to tell my grandmother
this is what we did, and
she should say, "Wow."
So if it doesn't excite or
surprise your grandmother,
there's something wrong
with your experiment.
It's not always true, of course,
but it's rough rule of thumb,
I think that's what I
was getting at there.
- You keep mentioning the
phantom limb experiment,
tell us a little about that
because our audience might
not be familiar with it, yeah.
- There are two experiments
we did, actually,
three experiments we did.
One was when you amputate an arm or a leg,
the patient continues to
vividly feel the presence
of that missing arm for
weeks, months, decades,
as long as 30 or 40 years,
and often it's excruciatingly painful.
Now one of the things we found was
if you touch the patient's
face on the ipsilateral side,
so let's say I'm the
patient, left arm is missing,
I take a Q-tip and touch
the left side of the face,
the patient feels the sensations
in his missing phantom arm.
Phantom limbs have been
studied for over a century.
People have discovered
there's a map of the hand,
a complete map of the hand on
the face of these patients,
not all of them, but many of them.
So here's a mystery fit
for Sherlock Holmes, right?
Why would you touch somebody's face,
and he feels their missing arm?
And it turns out the
hand portion of the map,
the entire body surface
is mapped on the surface of the brain
on the contralateral
side in a vertical strip.
It's a complete map of the body surface,
including the hand, face, everything.
And it's systematic map, point to point.
It turns out that the map of the hand
is right next to the map
of the face in the brain.
So when you remove the hand,
the hand area of the brain becomes hungry
for new sensory inputs, deprived of input,
and it becomes hungry for new input,
so the face input which is adjacent,
invades the territory
corresponding to the missing hand
and activates the cells there,
so there's a cross-wiring going on.
So that part of the brain now signals,
even though you're touching the face,
it misinterprets the signal as coming
from the missing phantom hand.
Therefore you say, my
hand is being touched.
And this shows that the brain is capable
of considerable reorganization
even in an adult
in a matter of a few days.
- And when you started out,
the notion of placidity
was not generally accepted,
and that is a major insight
that has come to neurology.
- That's correct, the
notion of neural plasticity,
there was always a minority group
who thought it was important,
but it was not widely accepted,
and nobody had shown it
in an adult human brain
in a simple manner that
we had set out to do.
The other experiment on
phantom limbs by the way,
many people have an arm
that's fixed or immobilized,
they have a paralyzed phantom limb,
sounds like an oxymoron, but they do,
and it's frozen, and it's
often an excruciatingly painful
position like that.
And I said what if you
get the guy to kind of,
volitionally open the hand
to make it less painful,
and I tell the patient
this, and he laughs at me
and says, "I've been
trying that for years,
"and it doesn't work, I
can't volitionally unclench
"my clenched phantom hand,
"the nails are digging into
my palm, it's painful."
So I hit upon the idea of
putting a mirror there,
so he could then clench his normal hand,
look at the reflection of the
normal hand in the mirror,
it'll look like he's seeing
his phantom hand clenched,
he's actually seeing the mirror reflection
of the normal hand.
Then he would send commands
to both hands to open,
he would unclench the normal hand,
it would look like his phantom hand,
which has been resurrected by the mirror,
is now unclenching.
He's getting visual feedback telling him,
hey look, your phantom is
moving again, it's unclenching.
And that's not surprising,
it's just an optical trick.
What's surprising is it causes the phantom
to actually move, it animates the phantom,
the phantom hand opens,
and the pain is relieved,
often instantly.
And this has now been
confirmed in clinical trials
and is being used throughout the world
as a treatment for phantom limb pain.
- And so what should we understand here,
that the fact that the limb is gone
has not registered with the brain?
- That's the main source
of the phantom limb,
but there are many things
going on in terms of the pain,
which is still being explored.
But what we had meanwhile
was a simple hunch
which led to a discovery that
enabled us to treat the pain.
What's even more surprising
is another disease
called RSD, reflex sympathetic dystrophy,
which is also considered intractable.
So normally when you think of pain,
there are actually two kinds of pain.
One is chronic pain,
which is like the pain
of a fracture or a bee sting,
and the pain then immobilizes a hand.
So you have a fracture
of the metacarpal bone,
a hairline fracture,
it would still be excruciatingly painful,
immobilized, inflamed,
swollen and painful.
The acute pain, like
you touching a kettle,
you withdraw the hand,
you mobilize the hand,
nothing else happens, you're fine.
But chronic pain is different.
It leads to inflammation,
swelling, redness and pain,
leads to all of those things.
Now usually in a matter
of a few days or weeks,
the injury heals, and
when the injury heals,
the pain subsides, swelling subsides,
redness goes away, the warmth goes away,
everything back to normal.
But in about 1% of people,
that doesn't happen.
The pain persists even
after the injury is healed.
The pain persists with a vengeance,
the swelling persists,
the redness persists,
the warmth persists, not only persists,
it extends into the hand, the
entire hand becomes swollen,
red and painful.
The entire arm becomes
red, swollen and painful.
And you're stuck with this
for life, for decades,
excruciatingly painful,
and it torments the patient
for their entire life.
How do you treat this?
Extraordinarily, we had
the idea of using a mirror,
and we suggested this, and
other groups have tried this.
You put a mirror there, and
you can look at the reflection
of the normal hand, a non-swollen hand,
in the mirror, optically
superimposed on the swollen hand,
so the swollen hand looks normal.
You move your normal hand,
the swollen, quote-unquote paralyzed hand,
starts moving again,
feels like it's moving,
not only feels like it's moving,
it actually starts moving,
and the swelling subsides,
the redness subsides.
You put a thermometer there,
you can measure the change in temperature.
All from visual feedback through a mirror.
This is the first time anybody had devised
a simple, non-invasive treatment
for RSD, and it's the treatment of choice,
now being used throughout
the world for RSD.
- What led you to the mirror?
Was it just a coincidence?
- Well, no, not entirely.
I said this guy is missing his arm,
and he feels if only he could move it,
move his phantom, it
would relieve him of pain,
so how do I make him move his phantom?
There is no arm to move there.
And I said maybe you can
visually resurrect the phantom,
maybe use virtual reality.
Then I saw this $5 mirror
laying around the lab,
and I said why use virtual reality
when you can use a $5 mirror,
so I placed the mirror there
and used it to resurrect his phantom,
so it was all through
accident and circumstance,
but my mind was primed to
think of this possibility.
- Do you think that virtual reality,
as that technology is developed,
will be an important
element in interfacing
with these visual mechanisms?
- Yeah, absolutely, yeah.
For example, the mirror can only be used
in unilateral amputees.
One arm is missing, use the other arm
to optically create the illusion
that his missing arm has come back.
But if you have both arms amputated,
you can't use a mirror, you
need to use virtual reality,
and in fact the parameters
are easier to control,
so now there are many,
many, many, many groups
throughout the world
implementing virtual reality
for stroke paralysis, for
RSD, for phantom pain,
for all these different types
of neurological disorders.
- In talking about your methodology,
I noticed you talk about science
should be problem-driven,
so on the one hand, it's problem-driven,
but insight comes from
anomalies basically,
and those two things
interact with your foundation
in what has come out
of different sciences,
in your case visual
sciences that you study.
- Yeah, I mean anomalies have the power
to drive new discoveries,
new directions of research.
Classic example of course
is continental drift
where Wegener saw the west coast of Africa
making a perfect fit with
the east coast of Brazil
and then looked and the
continents seemed to fit,
and he said how is this possible,
and everybody laughed at him
saying that that's absurd,
it's just coincidence.
He pushed his idea forward.
It's a classic example of an anomaly,
later turning out to be very important,
as a driving force in science,
in that case in geology.
Another case is bacterial transformation
where you take pneumococcus A
and incubate it with pneumococcus B.
One strain of bacteria being incubated
with another strain of bacteria.
And strain B changes into strain A.
This was reported long
before the discovery of DNA,
about a decade before
the discovery of DNA,
but it had no impact at all
in the world of science.
So here I am taking one
species of bacterium,
incubating it with another
A changes into B,
and it had absolutely no
impact on the world of science.
I'm exaggerating, there
were one or two people
who perked up, but by and
large it had no impact.
Now supposing I bring a goat to the room
and then bring a pig to the
room, put them in a room,
out come two goats, what would you say?
- Mm-hm.
- You'd jump up and
down and say, "My god!"
That's what these guys had done.
It just was bacteria
rather than goats and pigs,
but nobody paid any attention
because it didn't fit
mainstream thinking in science.
The notion of immutability
of species was so entrenched.
The notion that you
could change one species
to another species was unacceptable.
And then when somebody came along
and said you can just take
the juice of the bacteria
and inject it, juice turned out to be DNA,
so DNA was the genetic material,
people focused on that,
discovered the genetic code,
and the rest is history.
And I can give you dozens
and dozens of examples
in the history of science
where turning points
were anomalies or oddities.
Not the only way of doing
science, but it's one way
of approaching it.
- And in your background,
it's very interesting
because you have a philosophical sense
of the big issues that we need
to address in the long term,
but in the short term,
since neurology sort of
is in its early stages
of development if we compare
it to 19th Century science,
we are still mapping the brain
and figuring out what part
is related to what anomaly
or to what function, so
your medical background
as I understand it, leads
you to a clinical approach,
to actually find patients,
or patients come to you
with anomalies, and you really believe,
and for you it has worked,
to explore these anomalies,
to validate them, to make
sure there actually is
a pathology there, and then relate that
to the mapping of the brain.
- Couple of examples come to mind,
clinical applications.
One is the concept of metaneurons,
which is widely publicized these days,
where neurons in the front of your brain
ordinarily fire, motor neurons,
they're called motor neurons,
garden variety motor neurons,
they fire, messages go
through the spinal cord
out to the peripheral
nerves to the muscles
when I wiggle my finger or rub my thumb,
they're done by motor neurons.
Now 10% of these motor
command neurons in the front
of the brain will also fire
when you wiggle your thumb,
and I'm simply watching
you wiggle your thumb,
nothing supernatural in here,
visual input is transformed into,
it's computed to create
an internal representation
in my brain of your finger wiggling,
so the same neuron is firing
as when I wiggle my finger
as when you wiggle your finger,
and I'm watching you wiggle your finger,
so I'm creating a virtual
reality representation
of your movements, your
impending movements in my brain.
Now okay, this is fascinating,
it's a sort of mind-reading neuron
allowing me to predict your actions,
predicting your intentions
and so on and so forth.
That much everybody agrees,
but you could say it's
an arcane phenomenon,
what use is it clinically?
Well, one of the things
that a student of mine,
Jalal Baland, and I have
been exploring is OCD,
which is again a strange anomaly,
obsessive compulsive hand washing rituals
where people, they touch a doorknob,
they feel the urge to
incessantly wash their hands
with soap and water, go to
the bathroom repeatedly,
make sure it's completely spick and span
before they return.
Extremely really made an
impediment to their lifestyle.
So we thought, we hit on
the idea of simply saying,
well, why do you have to wash your hand,
there are metaneurons,
why not just watch somebody
else wash their hand?
- Hm.
- Now this seems like a cooky idea,
seems like a joke when
we first thought of it,
but it turns out it
works in some patients.
When they touch the doorknob,
and they get the urge to wash their hands,
they simply watch another person
washing their hands, and they get relief.
Not only that, you create a videotape
of somebody washing their
hand, they get relief.
Now the next step to
that is creating an app,
so when they get the urge,
all they need to do is look at a videotape
of themselves washing their own hands,
and it produces relief.
So it's a surprisingly simple solution
to a very, very intractable problem.
Now we need to do clinical
trials with placebos
to make sure this works.
All our experiments in
mirrors and phantom limbs,
already have been tested in
double-blind controlled trials.
This has not been tested yet,
but if it holds up, it's an
example of clinical application.
- And you also believe that mirror neurons
can help us understand autism.
- Yeah, well, mirror neurons
are undoubtedly involved
in empathy and in
constructing what we call
a theory of mind, and imitation,
and a lot of those human attributes
which we take for granted
which are part of being human,
and we were struck by the fact
that these are the very abilities
that are often missing
in autistic children,
so the link was obvious to
mirror neuron deficit in autism,
and we found some preliminary results,
but right now the evidence is in turmoil.
About half the labs in the world
claim that there's mirror
neuron deficiency in autism,
half the labs claim that there's nothing,
no difference in mirror neuron activity,
so I would say the evidence is suggestive
but not compelling.
We need to wait for the dust to settle.
- And in the way your mind works
as you study the mind,
what struck you and led you down this path
is when you list what we know
that mirror neurons are known to do,
and you list the deficiencies
of an autistic person,
those two match perfectly.
- Match perfectly.
- And so that is what opens a door for you
to explore this even if
ultimately it's disproven.
- Yeah, it's fine to be disproved
because as Darwin said, false conjectures
don't do any harm in science
so long as they're plausible
because in disproving them,
people take great delight,
so you made a lot of
people happy. (laughs)
- And science is as I learned
from Dr. Cicerone last week
is self-correcting.
- Yeah.
- And that's what its great virtue is.
- Yeah, psychologically speaking,
if you get everything
wrong, it's troubling,
but if you have a good
track record of getting,
let's say, four out of five
things right on average,
then you're doing well.
So you establish your credentials,
and then you have fun going on
a lot of fishing expeditions,
that's acceptable in science.
- Now.
- Only thing is when you're speculating,
you gotta be absolutely clear
when you're walking on thin ice,
you're saying this is speculative,
we don't know yet, we
haven't done the experiments,
this is just a theory,
versus when you have actually shown it,
then you can claim that you've shown it.
People often don't make that distinction,
even eminent scientists
and science writers
don't make that distinction.
It's important for the
scientist to make it clear
because the reader
doesn't have the expertise
to know when you're speculating
and when you're on unsure footing.
- Now interestingly enough,
your focus on mirror neurons
also leads you to a door that allows you
to speculate on culture
and how culture is transmitted
and what separates humans from apes,
talk a little about that
because this is a case where
you move from the particular,
you move from the pathology,
but then you see a way to talk about
how we transmit culture.
- Well there are two
aspects of mirror neurons
that I would emphasize,
one is the practical aspect,
which is often overlooked in the clinic,
and the other aspect is
the theoretical aspect,
which is what you're alluding to.
I just mentioned the practical
example of OCD being treated,
and we need to see if that holds up.
Another example is, by
the way, I'm going off
on a tangent here, but another example
is we know there are sensory
mirror neurons as well
in addition to motor mirror neurons.
If you go to the sensory
cortex in the brain,
the touch neurons, if I touch you,
somebody will touch me,
my touch neuron fires.
If I watch you being touched,
same touch neuron fires.
This is called, we call
them empathy neurons.
I like to call them Gandhi neurons
because they dissolve the barrier
between self and others.
Now, turns out however,
even though the same neurons
are firing, if somebody touches me,
or I'm watching you being touched,
when I watch you being touched,
I empathize, but I don't say,
I don't literally feel
the sensation in my hand.
Somebody pokes you with a needle,
somebody pokes me with a needle,
cells in my pain neurons
imitate a similar fire.
Somebody pokes you with a needle,
a subset of my empathy neurons fire,
same subset fires.
So why don't I shout "Ouch!"
when I watch you being poked?
Right?
Even though the same
neurons are being fired.
Well partly it's because I'm sensing it
but from my skin, it's
giving a veto signal,
it's saying, look, buddy, look, Rama,
Harry's being poked,
empathize by all means,
know what it's like to be poked,
but don't actually
experience it and shout out,
it would just be silly,
don't feel the pain, right?
So so far, so good.
So these neurons are
dissolving the barrier
between self and others
as far as quality of pain
is concerned, but so what?
So here is a patient with
excruciating phantom pain
in his phantom hand, there is no hand,
he wants to massage his phantom fingers,
he can't do that because
there are no fingers.
So he simply watches his
wife massage her hand,
and he gets a phantom
massage in his phantom limb,
and that relieves the pain
as effectively as mirrors.
So we need to do controlled experiments,
clinical trials on this,
but here's another example
of a clinical spin-off
for mirror neurons, but I'm
jumping ahead of myself.
Going back to your question of culture,
surely the important part
of cultural revolution
it's freed homonids
from the constraints of natural selection
at least in its very simple
form, is imitation learning.
A polar bear takes hundreds
of thousands of years
to evolve a fur coat through
laborious natural selection.
A human mother slaying a
polar bear, skinning it,
maybe learned as a trial and error,
a child watching her can use
his mirror neuron system,
I say mirror neuron system
because it's not just
the mirror neurons, to
imitate that behavior,
and that behavior is
transmitted in one generation
instead of evolving over
hundreds of generations,
so this surely must be origin of,
imitation learning is an important source
of what we call cultural
transmission of knowledge,
so I was speculating on that
aspect of mirror neurons
and arguing that it's a major step
in the evolution of
transmission of culture,
but not obviously, not the only step.
I mean it couldn't have been the only step
because the great apes have
mirror neurons I'm sure,
monkeys do we know for sure,
they don't have great culture.
So it may have been a necessary
step but not sufficient.
- You pointed out something a minute ago
that I think is important,
and that is the ability of
parts of the brain to cut off,
to stop going too far
in identifying with the,
what's going out that's not
part of your body basically.
Talk a little about that
because there is a tension in the brain
to on the one hand look
outward and identify,
but on the other hand to
draw lines that say, no,
this is me, and that's not me.
- Yeah, the me and not me distinction
is still being studied by many scientists
throughout the world.
It's a very tricky problem,
tricky philosophically,
tricky scientifically.
One example that comes to mind
is a study that I did with Jalal Baland,
who is a student of mine,
and what we found was,
we were looking at papers
on out of body experiences.
Now let's take metaneurons
again, in the front of the brain,
they allow you to adopt
another person's vantage point,
my mirror neurons allow
me to adopt Harry's,
your vantage point on the world,
temporarily enact your
view of the world, right?
Create a simulation.
But I don't feel myself drifting off
and fusing into you, a
kind of silly thought,
but that's what might,
you probably might expect
would happen.
Partly that's because of
anchoring provided by my own body,
so a chimp can, in watching another chimp,
temporarily adopt the other
chimp's point of view.
A human can adopt it even
when you're not here.
I can adopt another human
being's point of view.
I see myself rehearsing this
even in lecture in my mind,
an outsider's point of view,
but I don't leave my body,
that's sort of what you're asking.
Partly the anchoring comes
from the body itself,
from afference,
and in fact in a condition
called sleep paralysis,
where there's a complete deafferentation,
temporarily deafferentation,
sensory impulses from the
spinal cord to the brain,
temporarily while you're asleep,
while you're in REM sleep,
you do get out of body experiences.
One third of people in REM sleep
experience out of body experiences,
they feel like aliens are abducting them,
they are outside their own body.
This we think is caused
by the mirror neurons
being disinhibited.
This may have given rise to the notion
of disembodied souls, too,
which is relevant to the lecture
I'm going to give later today.
- Let's talk now about synesthesia,
you raised it a minute ago,
because in the case of that,
describe that condition,
but also the insights it
gave you about the brain.
- Yeah, well it's another
classic example of an anomaly.
It doesn't fit mainstream
thinking science,
and that was ignored for a hundred years,
discovered by Francis
Galton in the 19th Century,
first cousin of Charles Darwin.
He noticed that some people
in the general population,
he thought it was very rare,
people thought it was one in a thousand,
one in 10,000, we find
one in 50 people has this,
have this peculiarity that is
when they look at a number,
black and white number, black letter,
black number five or six or
seven printed on a white page,
they see the number colored.
There are two kinds of synesthesia,
called projectors and associators.
The projectors literally see the color,
if you go by their description,
they'll say, "The five
is, I know it's black,
"but it looks red to me,
"and it even has a halo of red around it
"like a neon light."
Some people say, "I know it's black,
"but it looks a beautiful
pink color to me."
So this is a classic
example of an anomaly.
First of all, why are they saying this?
Are they crazy?
Secondly, who gives a damn,
who cares whether these
people see numbers as color.
I can answer both those questions.
We embarked on this about 10
years ago for the first time.
First of all we showed they're not crazy,
they see the colors,
I'm going to touch on this
in my talk this evening,
they see the colors perfectly clearly,
just like you and I do.
You can show this by various experiments.
For example, if you have the number five,
and it's red, and you surround
it by a bunch of twos,
you have a black five surrounded
by a number of black twos,
normal people find it really difficult
to spot the black five
because it looks very much like the twos,
made up of the same vertical,
horizontal components,
so you got a matrix of fives
with a two in the middle.
You ask them is there a
two in the display or not?
And they find it very
difficult to answer that,
or take several seconds,
maybe 20, 30 seconds.
These people say, "Oh, I see a red two
"in the middle of green fives,
"in a forest of green."
And they do it much more quickly,
twice the speed of normal people.
This shows that we're dealing with
a genuine, authentic phenomenon.
Jamie Ward in London has
replicated this result.
This is what got us going initially,
and then what causes the
phenomenon of synesthesia,
it turns out that the
brain is of course modular,
the adult brain,
but in early infancy and in the fetus,
almost every part is
connected to every other part,
there's tremendous
redundancy of connections.
There are pruning genes
which then prune off
excess connections
between adjacent modules
to create the modular architecture
that characterizes the adult brain,
so you get for example,
an area for color in fusiform gyrus
in the temporal lobes,
little brain section
called the fusiform gyrus,
an area for color called V4,
then an area for number right next to it,
visual appearance of numbers.
These are normally segregated
in the adult brain,
but if there's a defect
in the pruning gene,
they get connected, and there's a mutation
there's hyperconnectivity
between adjacent brain regions,
and if this hyperconnectivity is expressed
by transcription factors exclusively
in the fusiform gyrus, which can happen,
you get number-color synesthesia.
Every time you see a
black and white number,
it activates the number area,
and it cross-activates the
color area in the brain,
evoking a particular color,
so five is red, six is
blue, seven is green,
so we have a solution to the mystery.
So we did the perceptual experiments,
and we did the brain imaging experiments,
and showed that we're on the right track,
but now comes the speculated part.
What this gotta do with creativity?
- Mm-hm.
- Think about creativity,
what do all artists, poets, novelists
have in common?
It turns out that synesthesia
is seven or eight times more common
among artists, poets and novelists
than in the general population.
Why would that be?
What's the link between synesthesia
and artists, poets and novelists
and genes pruning excess connections?
Well, if the defective pruning gene,
it's expressed not just
in the fusiform gyrus,
if it's expressed in the fusiform gyrus,
you get a color-number synesthesia,
this quirky phenomenon.
If it's expressed throughout the brain,
then assume that concepts and ideas
are also represented in
far-flung brain regions,
and you get a propensity to
link seemingly unrelated ideas
and thoughts, which is
the basis of metaphor.
For example when I say "It is the east,
"and Juliet is the sun,"
if I say Juliet is the sun,
you don't say she's a
glowing ball of fire,
you say she's warm like the sun,
radiant like the sun,
nurturing like the sun,
rises in the bed like the
sun rises in the east,
your brain forms all these associations,
and if you assume
concepts like young woman,
like Juliet, and sun, and radiance,
and all that are also in
different brain regions,
if you've got more connections
between different brain regions,
you have more scope for linking
seemingly unrelated ideas,
which is the basis of metaphor,
something that George
Lakoff here at Berkeley
has published on extensively.
- So from an apparent pathology
that you prove to be a pathology,
you come to an understanding
of the causes in the brain,
and then from that, in addition to saying,
yeah, this is real and
this is what's going on,
you wind up speculating,
and it is just speculation,
that we can get to the big questions.
- Correct.
- Namely, what is creativity,
is a process like the
one we've identified,
going on to a greater extent in the brain
and helping us understand
what creativity is.
- Exactly, so from the particular
to the broad, general questions.
Gives you an experimental foothold
for understanding things like metaphor,
which is, being so elusive.
- So in a way what's
really kind of interesting
as one has this conversation with you
is all of these factors that led you
to become a neurologist
in a study of the brain,
build pieces of a platform
from which you can not
only look at pathologies,
but also speculate
about the big questions.
- Yeah, absolutely, and neurology
is one of the few professions
where you can do that,
behavioral neurology
and cognitive neuroscience,
where any time you see a
patient with a disorder,
it's a curious disorder,
you come face to face with
the fundamental questions
that philosophers have raised
about the mind and brain
since, for the last 2,000 years.
- And you, in the last
chapter of your book,
you talk about consciousness.
Think aloud here and explain to us
how you're thinking about consciousness
based upon what you've learned
about the brain thus far.
- Well, unfortunately,
it's a loosely used word,
and somebody, Stuart Sutherland,
once said consciousness is a topic
about which a great deal has been written
but nothing is known.
(laughs)
And I feel sympathetic to his view.
There are two different questions.
One is a question of qualia,
how you can look at something red
like a red apple, and neurons firing away,
little wisps of jelly in your brain,
where's the red sensation come from?
An ancient question,
still not been solved.
And then there's the question of self,
the person who experiences a qualia.
They're two aspects of the same problem.
Now if you think of self
as one monolithic entity
but in fact there's many components to it,
it's a sense of continuity
in time and space,
your calendar, your sense
of being anchored in a body,
your sense of unity,
you, despite a diversity
of sense impressions and memories,
you feel like one person
and so on and so forth.
I think each of these
components can be studied
by neurologists looking at patients,
or doing brain imaging.
And finally some sort of
big picture will emerge,
but at this stage, we're still studying
the basic phenomenology,
phenomena tangentially
related to the problem
of consciousness, not a head-on collision
of the problem.
Your whole question
about what the self is,
it's called into question
when you see patients with a disorder
called anosognosia somatoparaphrenia.
The patient's right hemisphere stroke,
ordinarily the left side
completely paralyzed,
and they agree they're paralyzed,
they're bothered by it,
they wanna be treated.
But a subset of these
patients are paralyzed,
so here is a patient
with complete paralysis
of their left arm and left leg,
an elderly woman, and been paralyzed
for the last week or so,
right hemisphere stroke.
Normally, 90% of them,
95% of them will complain
about their paralysis.
Now there's about one or 2%
who are blissfully
indifferent to the paralysis.
You'll say, "Is there anything
wrong with you, Mrs. D?"
And they'll say, "No, I'm fine."
"Can you move your right hand?"
"Yes, I can move my right hand."
"What about your left hand?"
"I can move my left hand."
"Mrs. D, what is this?"
"Oh, that's my mother's hand,"
she would say with a
completely straight face.
"Your mother's hand?" I say,
"Where is your mother?"
"Oh, she's hiding under the table."
These are intelligent people,
there's nothing wrong
with their intellect,
and they're not obviously
emotionally disturbed,
but she makes up some
completely absurd reason
for her mother not being visible.
She's under the table.
Here comes the best part.
I say, "Okay, can you touch
my nose with your left hand?"
Sorry, "With your right hand?"
Of course she does.
"Can you touch my nose
with your left hand?"
She does this.
Now this implies that somebody in there,
despite her denial that
the left arm is paralyzed,
knows that the left arm is paralyzed,
otherwise why would you go and grab it?
Somebody in there also
knows this is her left hand,
not her mother's,
otherwise why should she grab it?
So there are many layers of iterations
that go into composing
what we call the self,
and this was brought
home to me very vividly
in this patient.
- So in a way you're
learning that the brain
does not like what you call equilibriums.
It comes through plasticity
to a way to configure itself
so it makes up for the
deficit, is that fair?
- Well there's some sort
of coherencing mechanism
undoubtedly, and we don't
quite clearly understand
what's going on, especially in disorders
like anosognosia somatoparaphrenia,
so I have sort not studied it in detail
for that very reason,
but the reason I raised is
not because you've studied it,
or understood it, but to
point out these enigmas
in neuroscience, surely
relevant to understanding
the concept of self.
Some cases, another example
I'd like to give you,
in which we have solved
the problem, I think,
is apotemnophilia, unpronounceable name,
so we changed it to an equally
unpronounceable xenomelia,
which means, the patient,
or a person I should say,
they don't regard themselves as patients,
as a problem,
all his life has harbored
a deep-seated urge
to have his left arm removed.
He's a perfectly normal person,
led a normal life in society, held a job,
had a family, had friends,
had a good sense of humor,
I recently saw a dean
from a medical school
with the syndrome. He came
to see me at the age of 70.
It happened five years after retirement.
And he said he's always had this urge
to have this arm removed,
and he wants to understand
what's going on.
He doesn't want to be cured,
but he dearly wants to
get his arm removed.
He doesn't see anything
abnormal about that.
And this it turns out, it's rare,
but not quite as rare as people thought.
You go onto the internet,
you can find people
with this, quote-unquote, this disorder,
or this wish to have their arm removed.
What's going on in their brain?
So I guess you have to
wait for the lecture.
- Well, one final question.
You wear so many hats,
philosopher, medical doctor, neurologist,
just to name a few.
How do you separate on
the one hand these roles,
but on the other hand
learn from each of them
because you have to be clear
that when you're a philosopher,
you're speculating.
- Yeah.
- It's not science.
- You sort of have to keep the
compartments quite distinct
in your brain, in your mind.
When you're seeing a patient as a patient,
I don't see patients clinically,
but I do help with the
treatment, devise new treatments,
and when you see him as a patient,
it's a very different mindset
when you're doing experiments on them,
and that's very important obviously.
And the philosopher aspect of it
is yet again is a different matter.
I haven't thought about it in detail,
so I'm not sure how easy it
is to answer that question.
- Well, on that note, I
wanna thank you very much
for being here and helping us understand
how you understand the brain
and this emerging field of
neurology, thank you very much.
- Thank you very much.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat music)